Okay, guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend, Hallo.
Mein Name ist Ustogollare. Ich bin hier, der, äh,
Diensthabender Arzt und möchte, mit Ihnen,
möchte ich mit Ihnen das, das Anamnesegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, gerne.
Ja, wie heißen Sie?
Schmet Thomas.
Oder umgekehrt Thomas Schmidt.
Schmet das in Nachname und Thomas in Vorname.
Schmet mit DT Amanda.
Könntest du dir bitte ihre Vor- und Nachname büchtern?
Thomas wie ist der Thomas?
THOMAS.
Und Schmet mit, Amanda mit DT, es ist,
SCH, MIDT.
Okay.
Und Herr Schmidt, wie alt sind Sie?
Siebzig Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ah, die, die, die Geburtstag meines, das ist das erste,
siebter, äh, neunzehntetsextzig.
Mit 50, ich glaub.
50.
Oder?
Ja.
50.
Ja, genau.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Äh, einsehbzig.
Okay.
Und wie viele sind Sie?
Äh, 80 Kilo.
80 Kilo.
Okay, Herr Schmidt.
Was für Sie zu uns, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Äh, ja, ich hab so eine lange Geschichte jetzt,
meine Hausarzt hat mich jetzt, äh,
hierher einfach geschickt mit, äh,
äh, Einweisung des, äh,
die Sache ins Krankenhaus geklärt werden müssen.
Ich hab so eine unangenehmes Bauchschmelzen,
ab und zu.
Und äh, ja, äh, so ein...
Seit wann haben Sie Bauchschmelzen?
Seit ungefähr mehr als, ja,
also, ich, dass es nicht dauerhaft,
aber ab und zu hab ich, ja.
Ja, ja, aber auch.
Ja, seit ungefähr drei Monaten.
Drei Monate.
Ja.
Und äh, wo, wo,
können Sie mir sagen, wo die Schmerz sind, genau sind?
Und die Schmerz sind genau sind.
Das ist auch schwierige Frage, dass Sie beantworten.
Sie sind weg, sind halfmal, links mal weg, ja.
So, mein, das ist Unterbauch oder Oberbauch,
ist das Ihre Frage so in dieser Richtung, oder?
Rechte Unterbauch oder linke Unterbauch oder Wahnsinnbauch?
Ja, das, das fangt manchmal mit dem,
im rechte Unterbauch und dann zieht sich nach links,
und dann manchmal in die Mitte fangt das an und zieht nicht nach rechts.
Ähm, und manchmal habe ich so eine, so eine Belühung in den Stark,
ähm, und dann habe ich dann Schmerzen und gesamter Bauch.
Äh, als ich gesagt habe, das kann ich nicht,
aber erst im rechte Bauchbereich, würde ich sagen,
aber das kann ich nicht genau jetzt lokalisieren.
Ja, ähm, ich habe verstanden.
Und die Streifen, die ich,
diese Schmerzen in andere Körperteile aus,
oder nur unter Bauch?
Nur im Bauchbereich.
Ist die Streifen in Rückenbereich aus oder?
Nein, nein.
Und könnt ihr Sie beschreiben,
sind die Schmerzen,
drücken die Schmerzen oder brennen die,
oder streichen die Schmerzen?
Säure drücken die Schmerzen.
Drücken die Schmerzen.
Und Sie haben gesagt, ab und zu,
und wie dauert, wie dauert eine Attacke,
z.B.
Wie lange dauert das?
Ja, wie lange dauert?
Ja, ähm, ja, ungefähr,
also zwei, drei Stunden manchmal,
manchmal da so zehn Minuten,
so unterschiedlich auch wieder.
Und äh, sind die Schmerzen im Verlauf immer schlimmer geworden oder?
Ja, in der letzten Zeit, das mehr geworden,
muss ich sagen, das ist schon mehr geworden, ja.
Haben Sie früher gleiche Schmerzen gehabt?
Nee, dann hat er mich vorgestellt,
ich habe das in den letzten drei Monaten, als ich das gesehen habe.
Ja, früher.
Drei, vier Monaten, aber vorher habe ich das nie gehabt.
Okay.
Und äh, haben Sie dagegen ein Medikamenter,
ein Genomen oder eine Therapie, ein Genomen?
Ähm, ja, ich habe von meinen Nachbarn,
also eine Schmerzmittel, äh,
sozusagen, zu sagen bekommen, äh,
die mich auch ein bisschen geholfen hat.
Und daraufhin habe ich denn die,
äh, die Vorstellung beim Haushaltsauch versöget,
äh, aber ich habe mich nicht vorgestellt,
muss man sagen, weil ich dann bis zur Richtung gekommen,
äh, war.
Und äh, das war so eine Troffenform,
Medikamentereist nicht genau, weil das war so ein...
Aber hat es, hat es nicht viel geholfen,
hat doch geholfen.
Aber ein bisschen.
Ja, schon.
Hat schon geholfen, ja.
Und das habe ich, äh, mich nicht jetzt, äh,
beim Haushaltsvorgestellt, als ich gesagt, vorzeitig.
Ich habe gesagt, dass es bestimmt durch die Nahrungs-
oder durch Unverträglichkeiten, oder,
weiß ich nicht genau, aller Gegendessen,
da habe ich gesagt, ja, aber uns habe ich auch Verstopfungen,
das ist ja durch die Verstopfung kann auch sein,
dass es das so auftretet.
Dann, wenn ich wirklich auch durchfahre,
naja, man versucht immer, eine Begründung zu finden.
Ja, Sie haben, erinnern, Sie haben manchmal Durchfall,
manchmal Verstopfung?
Ja, das hatte ich auch, das habe ich immer noch,
hab uns, ja.
Aber ja.
Und äh, es hat sich,
ihr äh, hat sich ihr, die Konsistenz,
ihres Schutuls verandert in Nesterzeit.
Oder westen durchfall oder früßige.
So eine, durchfall würde ich nicht genau sagen, ja,
sondern er, natürlich, ist es,
dünne Stuhlgang, es ist nicht genau so,
so geformt, dass er dünn zu sagen,
manchmal ist es richtig hart,
wie genau, wie man das Verstopfung beschreibt.
Aber so richtig durchfall habe ich nicht.
Ja, okay.
Hab es Übelkeit, Abbrechen?
Die Übelkeit habe ich auch in den letzten 2 Wochen gehabt,
also Abbrochen habe ich nie,
aber mir ist es schlecht auch in den letzten 2 Wochen.
Aber haben Sie nicht Erbrochen?
Nein.
Und äh, haben Sie Bemerk,
gab es eine bestimmte Ausdrucker,
der Schmerzen könnte sich etwas zahlen,
nachdem Essen, Schirme geworden,
oder Sie haben erwähnt etwas, aber?
Das habe ich nicht genau geachtet,
natürlich, nach dem Äh äh,
Nahrungsäh, Aufnahme,
habe ich ab und zu auch Probleme,
als ich so ein voller Gefühl habe,
ich brauche es voll und habe ich keine Lust mehr,
obwohl ich Hunger habe,
dann äh,
überlege ich mich immer, ob ich noch essen kann.
Das heißt, ich repetiere nicht gut.
Ich habe gute Appetit, als ich gesagt habe,
ich habe, ich habe Lust zu essen,
aber ein Versicht,
dieser volle Gefühl,
macht mich fix und fertig,
ja, macht mich fix und fertig,
dann man versucht zu vermeiden,
soweit es ermöglicht.
Dann haben Sie äh,
in der letzten Zeit,
Apotheos zu genommen?
Hm, gute Frage, ich gehe davon aus,
ich habe ein bisschen abgenommen, ja.
Ja, und wie viele Kilogramm haben Sie abgenommen?
Ja, ungefähr,
ungefähr, würde ich sagen, 5 Kilo.
Und welche Zeitraum haben Sie?
Auch in den letzten 6 Monaten, muss ich sagen.
Und äh, ja, hat sich Ihre,
oder haben Sie bemerkt,
die Verfassung der Haut,
gelbe Haut oder äh,
habe ich eine Änderung,
Verfassung, das habe ich gemerkt, ja.
Äh, nee, habe ich nicht gemerkt.
Ich habe es aber trockene Haut,
dass ich sagen habe, ja.
Trockene Haut, okay.
Haben, ähm, mhm,
haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, habe ich Fieber hatte,
habe ich nicht gemessen zu Hause.
Aber, äh, habe ich es manchmal warm, ja.
Warm.
Mir war es schon warm, ja.
Ich habe das verstanden,
Sie klagen über Verstoffung auch.
Nee, ja, ich habe als,
als eine von den ganzen Beschwerden sind auch Verstoffung.
Hm, ja.
Okay.
Aber auch gegenteil,
auch manchmal nicht Durchfall,
aber so dünne Schulwärme, ja.
Ja, ja, verstanden.
Und wie stark die Schmerzen
auf einer Skala 0 bis 10,
wenn nur die leichter sind,
ist sie sehr stark.
Wie können Sie sagen?
Okay, so eine Schmerz,
die ist zwischen 0 bis 10.
0 ist die...
Leichter, leichter.
Keine Schmerzen und 10 ist
den starksten Schmerzen.
Okay, würde ich sagen,
wenn ich Schmerzentage habe,
dann ist es zwischen 6 bis 8.
Okay.
Ja, ich finde.
Ja, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserwassen?
Nee, ich habe gar kein Problem.
Hm, haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Hm, ja, in der letzten Zeit schon.
Hm, können Sie gute Schlafen?
Nicht ganz, richtig.
Hm, können Sie nicht gute Schlafen
oder einschlafen?
Nicht gut durchschlafen.
Manchmal muss ich auf die Toilette gehen,
weil ich dann zum Beispiel
eine Schmerzentage habe.
Ja.
Wenn ich meine Studie gegangen habe,
dann geht es mir wieder besser,
muss man sagen, ja.
Nach der Studie ist besser.
Ja, ja, die sind besser.
Ja.
Hm.
Ja, ich hätte eine Frage.
Haben Sie das Gefühl, wenn ich aber die Haber gesagt habe,
okay, ich habe die gesagt.
Und haben Sie vor Erkrankungen?
Nee, ich habe nie Medikamente so in den Schein genommen.
Ich war immer gesund.
Ja, gut.
Und wurden Sie schon operiert?
Nee, bin ich auch nicht operiert.
Ja, schön.
Und haben Sie Allergie?
Oder um Verzweiflung?
Mir ist auch nicht bekannt.
Und rauchen Sie?
Auch nicht geraucht, nie.
Ja gut.
Haben Sie nie geraucht auch?
Nein, nie.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Auch nie getrunken auch.
Nicht getrunken, sehr gut.
Und das ist eine Routine-Fragile.
Haben Sie schon Druck und probiert?
Wie kann man sich vorstellen, wenn man Alkohol nicht beträgt?
Aber das ist eine Routine-Fragile.
Aber ich habe einmal Drohren zu mich genommen.
Wir haben es recht, aber trotzdem das,
als wenn man als Junge,
ja, das macht man alles.
Und sind Ihre Eltern gesund
oder haben Sie chronische Krankheiten,
wie ich wissen sollte?
Ja, ich bin 70 Jahre alt.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass Sie sich schon vor...
Und Sie sich nicht erinnern?
Ich kann mich gut erinnern, was Sie hatten.
Ist das Ihre Frage, ob Sie gesund waren,
ob Sie Krankheiten hatten oder was?
Ja.
Und Woran sind Ihre Eltern gestorben?
Woran die gestorben sind?
Ja, Woran die gestorben sind.
Meine Mutter hat seine Herzprobleme,
die hat ein Herzinfarkt,
am Ende ist sie verstorben.
Und mein Vater, der hat
so ein grünes Problem mit einem Darm,
auch mit einem Malen,
und am Ende weiß nicht,
was er hat, aber ist sie verstorben.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin der einzige Kind.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein.
Sind Sie geschieden oder nicht verheiratet?
Nein, ich habe eine Freundin.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Von Freund kann man nicht Kinder haben.
Was ist die Form beru?
Taxifahrer.
Ja, Herr Schimmitz,
ich habe für mich alle wichtigen Fragen gesteckt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzuführen oder fragen?
Nein, mir ist wichtig,
dass ich geklärt bekommt können,
was ich habe, oder wie ich damit umgehen.
Das ist mir wichtig zu wissen.
Ja, teilweise haben Sie,
ja, natürlich, eine Darmprobleme.
Aber ich muss das einige Diagnostische Masame durchführen.
Dann könnte ich das mehr sagen.
Und ja, aber, ja,
so etwas unter Suchung erwartet mich dann,
wenn ich fragen darf, was wir uns denn machen.
Ja, so etwas werde ich,
würde ich natürlich auch ein bisschen unterhalten.
Und danach würde ich
einen Brutabnehmung,
einen Brutparameter bestimmen.
Und dann
abbaubau,
dann durchführen.
Und ich werde dann
ein bisschen mehr Spiegelung durchführen.
Okay, das heißt erwartet mich noch
eine Menge von Untersuchungen.
Ja, Sie sollen auch,
ja, ich empfehle Ihnen stationäre,
stationär Aufnahme.
Stationär Aufnahme.
Das heißt, ich will so zerstören bleiben.
Ja, es wäre gut.
Ich möchte Ihnen stationär aufnehmen.
Es wäre gut,
es wäre gut,
haben sie Blut im Stuhl. Aber ich habe Farbe oder Konsistenz gefragt. Ja, da muss ich trotz
dem Blut fragen. Sie haben viele gesagt. Ich bin alt, ich bin 70 Jahre alt. Aber ja, Blut,
kein Zeit. Oder Farbe. Aber nicht Schwarze oder Tierstuhl. Ja, das sind immer Farbe, das ist
wichtig. Haben sie Schwarze Stuhl gehabt oder haben sie Blut im Stuhl gesehen? Das sind
zwei Fragen sollen sie immer stellen. Allgemein können sie alles fragen, aber dann kriegen sie
eine allgemeine Antwort. Okay. Ja, haben sie Blut im Stuhl bemerkt? Ja, also in den Klungen fragen sie das nicht.
Haben sie Blut im Stuhl gesehen? Ja, bemerkt kann man auch sagen. Das merkt man nicht,
das sieht man eigentlich. Ja, aber man kann auch so fragen, bemerkt kann man auch sagen.
Nee, habe ich nicht gesehen. Also eine Schwarze Stuhl hat sich gehabt in der letzten Zeit.
Ich weiß, ich weiß. Okay, haben wir noch Fragen? Ich glaube nicht.
Schweißausbruch, haben sie gefragt? Ja, nach Schweiß. Nach Schweiß, haben sie gefragt?
Ja, ich habe gefragt. Hab ich sparen gefordert? Ja, ja, Sie haben ein Ja gesagt. Okay,
sehr gut. Okay, und diese Stuhlganggeschichte können noch vertieft werden. Wie oft gehen Sie auf
Toyota? Da sollen sie auch das sind vertiefen. Das haben sie nicht gefragt. Ja, und als ich
gesagt, Verstoffung, natürlich Verstoffung, für mich, das geht normalerweise dreimal pro Tag
aufs Toyota, aber jetzt gehe ich nur einmal. Das heißt Verstoffung. Ja, das heißt für
mich Stuhlschwahl oder das heißt dünne Stuhlgangen. Da soll man aufkaren. Das war auch wieder
allgemein, aber. Ja, genau, das ist auch wieder so eine subjektive Sache. Ja, er hat
verstanden. Ich habe nur natürlich so rund beschrieben, damit sie das selbst entscheiden.
Ja, natürlich. Wenn ich das alles gekocht in geben, dann ist das alles einfach auch. Ja, ja, ich
bekomme, ja, ja. Ich habe verstanden, ja, ja, gut. Und Appetit ist gut, Sie haben
gesagt. Ja, ja, Appetit habe ich, Sie haben gefragt, Sie haben das beantwortet.
Appetit, aber ich habe eher so Probleme, so eine volle Gefühle, wie ich gesagt habe. Ja, ja, Sie haben volle Gefühle.
Okay, dann haben wir alles gefragt, alles beantwortet und geben wir weiter. Arztgespräch.
Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt, haben Sie seit ich möchte Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen?
Gerne. Ja, Herr Pommas, Jimit ist ein 70-jähriger Patient. Er ist 70 und 80 Kilogramm,
ein Meter 70 groß und 80 Kilogramm schwer. Und der Patient stelle sich bei uns wegen drei
Monaten, wegen seit drei Monaten aufgetretener, äh, durkender,
anfassartiger Bauchschmerzen, Bauchschmerzen, Unterbauchschmerzen vor und ja, die Schmerzen,
die Schmerzen straden im Ganzenbau auf. Versuchen Sie, Ihre Satz nicht so kompliziert zu bauen,
Sie haben versuchen, so ein Druckender, wie die, weiß ich nicht genau, so eine,
versuchen Sie die Satz kruiser und auch den nächsten, bei Schmerzen können Sie die Schmerzen
als beschreiben, wie stark es ist und wie, welcher Art er hat, die Schmerzen, ja.
Und so sind Druckende Schmerzen, auch mit dem, so zu sagen, Gewicht abnahm und so,
haben Sie nicht gewöhnt, aber die Satz ist immer kruiser und dann der nächste Satz,
das geht einfacher, auch in den Prüfungen, dann gehen Sie nicht durcheinander.
Mhm, okay.
Dann wird, ja, der Patientin berichtete das, die Schmerzen, die Schmerzattake,
ungefähr drei Stunden, andauert, ja, andauert, die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen, ja,
die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen, die Patientin berichtet, ob eine Schmerz,
wechselte Schmerz, hat Probleme im Sinne von die Schmerzen, dauern bis zwei Stunden
bei Schmerzattaker, oder während Schmerzattaker.
Ja.
Können Sie das auch so beschreiben?
Nein, Schmerzattaker.
Und die Schmerzintensität liegt auf einer Skala bei sechs bis acht von zehn
und die Patientin klagt über auch Obst-Passion, oder wechselte Stuhlgang,
ja, wechselte Stuhlgang, ja, wechselte Stuhlgang, ich tu, ja, wechselte Stuhlgang,
ich tu, ich, dünne, dünne und manchmal hart, und die Patientin, der Patient,
der Patient habe gegen die Schmerz tropfen,
Schmerz mit der Angenomen,
aber ich habe ihr geholfen
und der Patient habe innerhalb von sechs Monaten 5 kg abgenommen
und er habe in Brut in der Schütte bemerkt
und er habe Melena
seit ein Wochen
2 Wochen, 3 Wochen
und er hat auch Neusea, volle Gefühle im Bauch
und heise Gefühle nach Schweiß
warme Gefühle nach Schweiß
der Patient war Hausarzt
und der Patient hat uns angewiesen
und er hat keine Erkrankungen
und er wurde bis her nicht operiert
Das haben wir auch nicht gefragt, auch leistungsmäßig, wie es ihm geht, wie die Leistung ist.
In der letzten Zeit natürlich, in der Mesa, weil wir uns auf den Darmproblemen konzentriert haben.
Wenn man sagt, ich habe so ein schwarzes Studium seit zwei Wochen,
dann soll man auch fragen, wie es ihm geht mit dem Belastung.
Das gehört auch dazu eigentlich.
Das ist ja auch mindestens ein Kardialproblem, die er in der Litnext letzte zwei Wochen,
dazu gekommen ist, so zu sagen, zu anonymisieren.
Das ist auch wichtig.
Das sollen sie auch machen.
Wenn es so etwas wie Melena, der ist schon Blutverlust und daher
natürlich auch schon Kardialprobleme vorursachen.
Nur für sie als Tipps kann man auch sagen, dass es eine X-Prande ist.
Und ansonsten, sie haben vor Recht in der nächsten Mache eine Darmspiegelung,
unbedingt auf der Vorbereitung, und dann gehört natürlich Stand-up City.
Da ist das alles klar, in welche Richtung geht das.
Das ist also einfach Fall natürlich.
Im Sulphur abends auch mal nicht so ein schöner Fall,
sondern nicht eine enticrylorische Fall, sondern auf so einer Krebsfall.
Das ist immer das einfachste.
Nein, nein, nein.
Die letzte Falle war, das haben wir zusammen gemacht.
Wir haben sie gemacht.
Wir haben uns die Nähfutter gemacht.
Wir haben mit ihnen.
Wir haben mit der Atmung die Bestimmungsdammung gemacht.
Mit der?
Atmung.
Der macht auch.
Der ist auch im Kurdhauer.
Weil nix mal machen, dann dann auch noch ein schönes Hauschen machen.
Ansonsten haben sie es gut gemacht.
Das ist auch im Kurdhauer.
Wir zwetschern zwischen der ämerthologischen und klorischen Geschichte.
Leider.
Wir haben es gut gemacht.
Wir gehen nicht jetzt in den Tief, was man haben können.
In diesem Fall ist er bei der Rechtszeit in Darmkrebs zu sagen.
Links erwartet man nicht.
Links erwartet man erblut.
Rechts erwartet man er verstoffen.
Grunsch Probleme.
Daher würde ich sagen,
das ist eine frechliche Frage.
Wenn die das fragen,
dann sind die frech.
Als Täter.
Und die Koloren müssen auch darauf schauen.
Ja, das ist so.
Einfach als Chirurin, die machen sofort viel, aber als Koloren will niemand drüber gehen.
Natürlich kann man das machen, aber als Blende würde ich niemand empfehlen.
Man kann das nicht mehr als Chemotherapie geben.
Hier in Deutschland, das ist nicht vergleichbar wie in der Türke, ich habe auch dort gearbeitet, ich weiß wie das läuft dort leider.
Hier ist es alles in Piedern, natürlich hier läuft auch vieles schief, das muss man sagen, es läuft nicht alles in den grünen Bereich.
Aber man versucht immer nach Leitlinien zu machen.
Und in Leitlinien muss man genau schauen, in welcher Stadion es ist.
Und wie man damit umgehen soll, eine Neuadjuvanttherapie anbieten, oder ob man die Operation anbieten soll.
Das ist eine Sache, die man genau diskutieren soll.
Vielleicht in der Folgen Sie, in Amerika leiten Sie?
Nein, in Deutschland leiten Sie.
In Europa, die auch den Zulassung, dass in Amerika ist, das wird nicht hier zugelassen.
Den Zulassung von jeder Krankheit, jeder Medikamente kommt von immer.
Europaschausneinmetall sind daher, was in Amerika zugelassen ist, das wird nicht automatisch angekannt.
Sie haben eine deutsche Standards.
Ja, manchmal habe ich den Chef gesagt, dass der USA die Stande schiebt.
Ja, genau, die haben ihre Stande selbst.
Das ist auch gut in vieles gelaufen, in jeder Bereich, in Syrups, in Ökologien, in den Gründern.
So ist es.
Okay, Sie haben es toll gemacht.
Die Medikamente hat recht gehabt.
Gut, dann kommt er.